okay I see the green line okay all right
good morning my name is Belinda yeah
Lieberman I I work at the Cleveland
Clinic and my job title is on the
medical director of clinical and the
molecular biology laboratory so I'm a
lab person I'm not OBGYN so title of my
talk today is cervical cancer a
preventable disease the role of a human
papilloma testing that's what HPD stand
for in a clinical lab I have some
disclosure on this slide now I would
like to go over four or five points this
morning and first what everyone need to
know about the human papillomavirus and
what's the clinical significant
over-testing HPD in women and also
letting you know i think it's not
evidence showing they're actually fda
cleared to vesting on to prevent human
papilloma infection or cervical cancer
in women and this is the first time
vaccine actually literally can cure
cancer and it's a very exciting time and
share with you what we do here at the
Cleveland Clinic Cleveland Ohio is right
in the middle on north middle of the
United States so we have been doing a
testing of human papillomavirus by
molecular tests also doing the pap smear
at the same time so we call this code
testing I'll share with you some of our
experience doing code testing Cleveland
Clinic and we've been doing this for
almost ten years last but not least ty
has come
then the question we're going to ask is
a king the molecular pap that is HPV
test can serve as a primary screen so
the first you slay I introduce you and
beam biologist we're going to learn a
little more about human papillomavirus
or wood from their own light is going to
call HPD so human papillomavirus HPV is
actually the most common sexually
transmitted infections in the United
States I'm sure in the world was about
in United States about 6.2 million cases
diagnosed every year that's astonishing
also same time at two thousand eight and
the Nobel Prize was awarded to dr.
Harrell zool Hobson the reason is he
actually is being a pathologist let
person he discovered the human papilloma
virus that caused the reason cause
cancer cervical cancer in women so this
is a very no interest in fact to know so
again so HPV is right now established
the lot of publication and fats and the
proof that human papillomavirus is the
primary causal factor of cervical cancer
and cervical disease in women so quickly
how did this happen so little bit
history in 1980 dr. Harrell housing
pathologist in Germany he linked several
cancer with HPV I would describe what he
did he saved a lot of slides as a
pathologist people a woman died to
cancer they you know pathology were do a
biopsy they make a block aceite they
saved the the cells in the paraffin
block they cut a blog make this slide
they read the slide looking for evidence
of cancer looking cells and that's what
he did and he did a lot apparently they
say
lot of Sly and the woman died of
cervical cancer or similar type of
disease and then he was able to show
them look in the slide and looking for
evidence in the cells of the women that
disease and during due to cancer looking
for evidence of human papillomavirus
footprint so what he essentially did his
homework Oh inside your hybridization he
was able to find 99.7 percent is almost
hundred percent of all the slides from
women died from women from cervical sway
my cell cancer they all have human
papillomavirus nucleus a sequence at the
same time a different group of women
they're younger than 30 they had
adenocarcinoma in a woman it's a
different area of the service and then
eighty-nine percent of those sample
showed evidence positive evidence HPV he
was also cloning lot of a virus I so at
that time 1980 he already had developed
the different type of the human
papillomavirus so he actually published
indicating the type 16 and type 18 were
the worst and that if the cancers lot
worse and then also list 31 35 45 51 52
delamo i will show you later this all
correlate the presence of this subtype
HPV correlate or the presence of
cervical cancer in women and he also did
a statistic around on almost forty
percent of women when they are positive
for 16-18 subtype HPV they eventually
developed advanced into no sea silk what
you're saying to same three enemies
cervical intraepithelial neoplasia then
his tumor and then in within two years
this is really shocking and good
evidence showing about this time when
dr.
hey Harold do heusen was working on this
starting 4 1980 and here a few years
later but not until nineteen ninety-six
that is 16 years later the wh 0 european
organization as well as national
institute had a health all we endorse
recognize that this is the cost of
cervical cancer human papillomavirus so
this is a sly i got from the google wind
dr zoo howson except he's Nobel laureate
a price he gave a quick speech was a
really nice diagram then anybody can see
can can be helped convinced what he was
saying he said the HPV is a DNA virus is
it double stranded DNA small virus about
50 nanometer in size and then it has the
envelope co capsid and so it's a
circular double string is also no notnot
envelope recorded naked the virus is
protected by a co capsid protein and the
he also mentioned there more than 100
different type h human papilloma types
were known and discovered among those
HPV 16 18 cause seventy percent or the
all the cervical cancer in women at that
time when he studied then how did it
happen this virus are in fact easily in
fact epithelial cells in a cervical
mucosa and the HPV DNA that is the
nucleus of the virus it will integrate
into the Cedars epithelial layer this
virus enter it will settle down on the
base of infected basal cell then
throughout the weeks weeks the virus
will replicate from one cell to cell to
your spread throughout the other cell
and so not only spread and then also
they complete in your replicate and
then going to in depth to throw the
entire layer this is the time he
mentioned lot of times when people have
this this the time if individual has
good immune assistant potential they
actually nineteen ninety percent 90
percent the individual actually heal
within two years we also know there's
many many article mentioned that human
papilloma rice is he in fact most common
in teenagers and women and the back in
the early 20s but the decrease in
prevalence and here before about age 30
most allowed Lincoln clear over ninety
percent and this is what he was trying
to address and this has been shown by
many other investigator aye sir in fact
the epithelial continues 10 to 30 years
what that means people never get tested
they never know because it is
asymptomatic so 10 to 30 years later
that virus will be integrated into the
invasive cancer they integrated in the
chromosome so the included in the tumor
cell DNA and they eventually end up
because invasive cancer remember no
matter what happened in the case of this
the cervical cancer is a curable disease
bear that in mind so quickly on the
virus is belong to a family called
Petrova virus that means a small DNA
with double strand DNA DNA virus small
and they have a little sort of capsule
more than 100 different type it is very
invasive you like to invade mucosal
membrane skin through laceration and
then they're different strengths produce
different lesions and they have a tropic
trophies enemies they pre delict for
certain type of cell and so they like
your skin genital and oral mucosa was
easy to enter now again I next slide
showing you know all this type of human
papilloma this is all been published
an experiment document you can see all
kind of disease on the left side start
from comer war plaintiffs were flat were
all anal genital were all the way to
oral papilloma and misha lodi for us her
recently blood of head neck cancer is
also frankly founder human
papillomavirus but the ones i have a
highlight here is as general cancer this
subtype of 30 so HPV otherwise they have
shown connection correlated with causing
part of a poor color the human cervical
cancers so this is as we don't need a
member i just showed is almost like
family tree of the hundred more than 100
different kind of HPV they are sort of
all from wine group pepper popova lee rd
but they are human papilloma virus the
one highlight in red on the top to slide
this the one they have been shown
correlator related i have a cost show
the reason that cost cervical cancer in
human and there are three they are in
determinants you know 26 5366 type they
are cost but much lower risk and then
against the same thing this time with
high-risk and low-risk about this line
he says mucosa genital HPV type above
this line this odd that we call it Louis
Louis does not mean no no risk and then
the genital wart as well so when you see
lower great pep changes when and
psychology free to select open time they
are some this type and then below this
line you know this highlight in yellow
their high grade changes so this group
of Rs here we call the high-risk human
papilloma res also a lot of people call
HPV H R that means high risk so the the
type of HPD written in the letter in the
blue box this is the one currently the
FDA approved HPV test be in PCR
hybridization and the currently they
that's what they are using for the HPD
tests they used by many people's lab at
hospital including our lab so I mention
to you about their blessing and then dr.
Hauser at a number of price now finally
vesting best thing was developed two
years before dr. zole house and got his
Nobel Prize maybe the trigger so there
are two HPD vesi by merck by girl XO
were arroz con and they both have the
16-18 time but the Merc has 16 18 6 and
11 so this is the one most people use
and we call them quadrate Maryland and
even the that is good news because
they're vesting for more than 10 20
years studies showing you actually can
prevent advancement of cervical cancer
printing cancer is be investigated early
and this is the vial from the mercure
quadrivalent is caught in that cell now
so since we know HPV is the primary
cause cervical cancer we also know there
are hundred different type we also note
about 30 son subtype they are high-risk
high-risk means they are linked to Casa
cervical cancer so the so the what's the
rover laboratory so if you can detect
sample detective positive high-risk HPV
detachment HPD in the sample is
associated with two hundred fifty fifty
time risk increased risk of a hi Gracie
I enemies high grade cervical
intraepithelial neoplasia neoplasm means
tumor so in high-grade eventually you're
going to have
answer and then I mentioned the 30 type
and the primary is in fact the squamous
them so so worldwide quickly stat you
know in 2002 I just glanced the 2012
statistics it's almost the same so in
2002 worldwide almost half a million
women didn't develop the cancer and you
can see 274 is about 50 liberal over
fifty percent you know other individual
they died from cervical cancer and they
estimated 291 million women are infected
with high-risk HPV type remember many
times unless he gets really advanced age
they're totally asymptomatic stay in the
United States like about eleven to
twelve thousand cases of cervical cancer
are being a diagnosed in 2012's show Bob
McClure liberal higher than 11,000 and
but annually if you check on a statistic
even google about 4,000 deaths annually
which can be prevented remember and
that's why the laboratory tests couldn't
play major role together with the best
thing in United States every year 6 to 8
million cervical infection they also
they it was reported that's really high
and so this is a paper everybody call it
a final pathologist it's very very good
showing that moon even woman really
clear the HPV infection within 9 50
months due to the in tech community know
that that you need and so HPV infection
can be you know Layton means quiescent
for many years the only way you can find
out is to get tested there's four when
you go get your physical there will be a
good time to ask if that's possible and
HPD a development we mentioned if you
develop positive is
250 for your higher risk than the others
and then also persistent the most
important part is this let it work
persistent if you continue have HPD if
you don't get test you don't know so you
can live until you get older boom you
can be diagnosed with cervical cancer so
persistently high risk HPV is necessary
for the development of advanced cancer
this is the same a different dog that
deliver the same message is showing that
in them and the upper leather you can
sell on the top line normally you know
that the epithelium service look like
this no more sir is nice lined up really
nice and the if the virus particle can
you settle down on the base layer start
replicating and you start having
abnormal the psychology is going to read
a slide there you'll find out srl means
squamous intraepithelial lesion they so
show this abnormality in your cervical
cells and then if you keep going from
the virus infect the celtics play infect
more you can actually go to cervical
intraepithelial lesion is really
apparently easily be identified by
cytology even the cervical
intraepithelial lesion CIA it has CIA
123 the higher the number the worst
disease eventually tumors that form the
cell because tumor then the HPV genome
is incorporated in the entire the
epithelium player may now you have an
invasive cancer and then this everyone
already know you have HPV infection when
you get first because in analyzing
factor you can clear most of them
however ninety percent thing clear but
you don't know right so those who have
persistent let's say ten percent
individual persistent HPV infection
eventually we talked about this
regulation or cellular
yeah and then just keep going to the
right side of the slide since there's no
detection no treatment and then you're
going to advance into high grade and
tumor and eventually you have invasive
cancer this area once from persistent
HPV enter into the cellular
dysregulation this is all we call code
carcinogens the virus actually costs the
cancer quickly i'm not going to dwell on
this i just leave this slide because we
keep saying low gray high grade what's
asked us ask us means at the very
beginning possible your pap smear you
can ask us almost like equivocal in the
lab it means a typical day look not a
typical squamous cell but they don't
know what's the significance there they
will signed out as ask us and then so
there's something is little bit abnormal
and then there were events in the low
grade high agree eventually we have no
all this other terminology and I list
this because psychology sometime
nomenclature based different histology
but they all are correspond the same
thing so it were met as you can see the
red area is the high high prevalence
again I did the same thing here showing
2007 the United States 11,000 a cases
and 3600 death and I just a statistic is
from 2007 but you used to out the entire
world is it's not it's a worldwide if we
don't do the test it continued spread
and to the next generation so move on
quickly and psychology so I know the
reason we call Pat and I don't know
audience realized dr. pepper Niccolo the
first three letter of dr. pepper
Nicholas name is Pat that's why pap
smear is used as he's using his last
name just three letters
and and two so pap smear 50 years ago he
was pathologist and then it was for
Europe and then immigrated to cornell
university where he noticed tumor cell
looking in in the cervical washing and
he's very interesting psychology so he
and his partner continued about but I
think 19-43 they published paper and
they showed the abnormal cell and then
by 1950 I think pet was cleared and
start using so what I'm about you know
50 60 years ago because the you know the
invention develop and implement pep and
fifty percent of the cervical cancer
cases we keep retouching throughout the
past 40 50 60 years so it's real
significant quickly the next slide
showing at the upper / showing the
old-fashioned Pat you just go to
cervical washing you make a slide notice
all the bacterium could be alecto
bacillus you'll be a microbiology so
there if they look really crummy a
junkie and then the psychologists were
to try to make decision is this cervical
cancer or not but in 1996 we call it
liquid liquid Pat liqu ID so the pub
it's a liquid is in a liquid so you
suspend the cell the liquid pet is made
of mostly fifty percent methanol another
company's fifty percent ethanol when you
put the cells in the alcohol-based their
cells get fixed so klingt up so suddenly
you can see how easy to read by doing
this I think they increase significant
crease the sensitivity of the pap smear
readout so as shown in the next slide
the prevalence of the genital HPV and us
females are roughly 1900 specimen and
female 14 to 50 year old and then
overall twenty-seven percent of this
1907 they were all posited by test in
the lab positive HPV
when you separate the age you see the
prevalence you can see the highest is 22
a 14-year to 24 year you know they reach
anywhere forty to fifty percent that
means why every two young girls they
have HPV and then the rest and then
young people like me I'm on this
category but you can see the rest they
only the 0 state by the same
consistently twenty four to thirty
percent throughout the internet about 60
year old that tells us the HPV test need
and so I need to order the HPV test
because there's a treatable disease you
can get rid of HPV so this is quite
alarming and also the screening and this
star belong tango and then showing that
long tango number of a woman and roll
for the study from Germany all the way
Portland him I think our doctor Bellas
are making the one did the China Study
and then I pat and your peplum is you
put the cells on the slide you read you
notice the sensitivity overall yeah from
50 all the way to 90 so it's very
variable depends where you are and then
you do the HPV and I remember HPV the
lab technician we don't do anything we
put in the machine so it's automated so
you can see it's much better okay 70 but
all the way to hungry so but neither
then is perfect right so but tusa early
2000 2004 2002 the American College of
ob-gyn or American Cancer Society
recommended maybe we should do coke Co
testing that means you test both you
take one sample you do both so HPV
prospect become co testing you notice
sensitivity is really good and that's
why at the Cleveland Clinic we started
co testing 2000 for every woman over 30
and just to swap why is a liquid pap the
other one is a is called a
specimen Transport has a dieter
detergent we've been doing a sense but
before to get to go on the other slide
let me tell you I remind you again
having the high-risk 1618 HPV type you
cost seventy percent of cancer and also
we have a vessel vaccine has 16 18 it's
really important encouraging young girls
and young boys yet resonated and those
of us who are parents and then also
study showing what's the q me the
instant array so they follow individual
for ten years and they found out they
want the advance into the cancer the
risk and they usually are the people
their sample have 16 and 18 together is
about 31 it the other high-risk you go
to 10 years is still thirty percent so a
three percent three percent does not
mean zero percent so therefore the newer
and I understand the other dressing is
in the making they're going to add other
type of HPV so by now hopefully
everybody listen to the present hope I
convince you that the test for the high
risk HPV who you combine with pet a pet
it's more sensitive it's better for
patient you early detection you're
leaking treatment and so a positive
high-risk HPV is that the most important
risk indicator for the development of
the high grade because HPV have been
shown is the cause of cervical cancer so
this so tired not in selenium be
derogatory so the laboratory those of us
are working in the clinic lab sure feel
responsible this is a test we can offer
to patient so what's the standard cared
I already mention this American Cancer
Society American Society of ob-gyn and
so you can see both
i D I think ur co testing what is better
than pact or HPV separately and so they
encourage la the hospital Institute to
start offering co testing but this was
2005 2004 2002 and it just right here in
Cleveland our hospital started 2004 so
here's a Cleveland it I just might share
with you briefly our experience so and
we know we are look Cleveland as the
lake erie is the Northeast Ohio on the
top Ohio across the water will be Canada
and then we Cleveland is a 13 back
hospitality hundred a hospital we also
have 18 outpatient clinic because this
way patient do not the drive downtown
the drive downtown liquor the blood
pressure they get a parking so so they
decide the deploy we deploy all the fun
out of it outpatient clinic many years
ago too easy for the patients with
access to the doctor we also have almost
seven smaller community hospital for
they have hospital bed they can do a
different kind of surgery and it's the
last reference lab so currently our
volume is about 42,000 none this 42,000
tests are all are reflex or co testing
only so we do this many we do HPV screen
or the women and also reflects that is
for Pat and we do this five days a week
quickly what we do hyper catcher I think
the people in the lab will find this
it's a simple technique if you have a
hundred 110 plug e electric plug and the
instruments real easy and you can really
offer this test and that's how we we
started the we started the new 2010 for
your lives with detergent you heat up
the tube so then you are you you
separate the other junk with the DNA
a precipitate on the bottom so DNA has
the double string and then you heat up
the DNA separate become single string
that's when ultimately the company has
the arm a probe that is HPV RNA is there
are 13 subtype of HPV sequence so all
stitching here so if your patient sample
hybridize with this it tells us the
patient is positive so once they
apposite they form this little like a
double helix and therefore they fall in
the helix and that's where they have the
junction of RNA and DNA hybrid right
that's our ma this is DNA so long time
going the company called I team is there
being sold to paging and so dodging and
they develop proprietary monoclonal
antibody that will capture the rna-dna
hybrid so when you pour your sample into
this tube on the along the War of the
tube is coded a film coder of a
monoclonal antibody minute you drop the
the Ganesha of the cervical cells that
heated and the Edda probe they going to
be captured by the monoclonal after this
you do extensive washing you'll find out
the only thing your left is the captured
HPV DNA in question and then theory
Invisibles how do you make this visible
they take the monoclonal antibody same
but they label them with alkaline
phosphatase the little look like cherry
tablets and berries happen at the end of
the ID GJ ok this is this will buy with
also the hybrid on the other side whilst
they bind and this Ocalan phosphatase
you add something konima fast luma fans
will result in a release a
chemiluminescence signal so suddenly the
light amid is reading in a luminometer
and then the higher the sort of more
darker the life or higher the relative a
la una
higher the HPV soda mera law is not a
quantitative test but it does tell you
some really weak or weekly reactive and
strong reactive sample since we've been
doing this since you know we're late
1990s oh we have a lot of experience so
and this is the Machine and its really
hands-on now because everyone's doing
code testing and then American Society
clinical psychopath pathology guidance
showing that for people doing cool
testing suddenly you're going to have
five different category so that caused a
little bit complication but those are in
the lab we just busy doing the test but
why sort of Sly I was little bit
surprised but in a way of happy to see
they were able to divide by patients
result in five different sets and then
this algorithm recommendation for to do
if your test negative by HPV in a
psychology you you come back three years
three to five years that new
recommendation if you're hpv-positive
the path the slice negative you come
back 12 months and your reverse the
slant HPV is negative but you have
atypical squamous cell of unknown
significance and then you also come back
so these people this is no risk people
these people need to come follow next
year and then if you have HPV pass also
abnormal pap all packed with an advanced
psychology you go right to the capacity
that's where you go get biopsy make this
biopsy it didn't go to psychologist so
this is the most severe case on the
right left side and left side is less
severe so now you know for me I've been
doing this you know ten years the way
start asking its code testing good
enough in the remember Barry my every
time you women come you're going to do
two tests wines pep once HPV many times
they don't agree that's life many times
don't you agree and then you're thinking
well when they get this what do the
doctors do what we do is repeat so by
doing this and you realize it gets
increase in cost so in the area of a
costly persisting reposition and let
everyone's a lot more aware cost you
want to offer test not only not
increasing costs but good test efficient
and fast so now we start now with we
need and discuss with all the new HPV
test available so you perform two tests
on all women increase the cost so we
want the so how about we just want to do
pick one of the good acid and do it so
the code testing have a lot of
challenges and we've been talking about
but now I think solution is is is coming
so so we're talking about future so the
last many years in all the meeting I go
is what's best and young that means
what's after HPV code testing and then
so many people are resource poor people
they just do HPV test or this is I
finger ronco is from italy i believe so
he did a study showing their data
suggests the supplementing HPV test with
psychology psychology has no advantage
little advantage so they recommend we
need to reassess using HPD as a primary
screen one positive we triage to
cytology this way we'll be happy we're
not overburdened with the lab and this
was 2006 remember that day 2006 and
another study okay i'm trying to raise
and so in the necessary show you some
and young is maybe you know pap smears
good someone has to read by naked eye
maybe a molecular paps going to come so
we had a lot of meeting we talked about
maybe would since the molecular is run
more sensitive let's talk about
molecular screening so New England
Journal
published two 2007 they talked about we
are in the room talk about so I have a
to test the molecular test is very
sensitive but a psychology you know the
window psychologist world trends i will
read the slide they are very specific
and those of us in the audience we
worked in the lab we were always taught
use the more sensitive test to screen
and then confirm by a more specific test
right we stay in my maybe the time has
come so maybe this last time going to
see this cytology so the so hum put up
the future is here so the government by
early the government-sponsored study and
it's called cervical cancer screening
program they only use HPV and this was
2007 i believe i was in one beneath him
dimension and the 2009 at 2,000 men we
have an india physician went back to
India and then do the same thing since
the resource pool people don't have time
to scared your money to see a doctor
have a nurse collected patna or that I
believe they were doing self collection
and the only test for HPV so in the law
low-resource setting a single around HPV
test that's one time was associated with
significant reduction in the number of
advanced cervical cancer a desk from
cervical cancer this study went on for
many years finally published in nuclear
journal it was really exciting i
remember we gather everyone's talk about
it and this is a really good and of
course not local newspaper quickly say
yes nu da test Sunday's going to replace
Pat that means we're going to have a
molecular pad right so last month and
the good news last month FDA finally
clear and test user is from the company
Roche is called Kobus HPV test and it's
down by real-time pcr what is real 20
here different from pcr this why is all
the samples in one tube one sample
tube but you can put on 14 different
kind of a sequence approp you know in
one setting and all together so you can
you notice the road test their probe the
pcr primary probe include 14 high-risk
HPV you can see that they put the 12
hirez here the two real bad one here
here what does channel me we do
real-time pcr the multiple channel in
the pcr a thermal cycler and the channel
/ a different kind of wavelengths
depends how you put a guy on the probe
so so you can see the 12 high-risk a
different bag ey e and a channel two is
a different diet and channel 3 is 18 and
channel 4 is internal control so they
were not running into each other in the
computer so they did a study for many
years and roll 4050 cells in individual
so you can read here is it it's an
integrated genotype sa not only they
detect all the high risks at the end of
the test they also can tell you whether
your patient has 16 18 because remember
this too are the one seventy percent the
cancer costs due to this too so we
usually call 1618 oncogenic HPV types so
this allow reporting the whole result
also report do they have the real bad
ones so what's the test algorithm so the
FDA rick has a expert group panel and
discuss and then finally the
recommendation is as such that you have
your patient tested if your patients
negative for everything negative easels
go follow up and could be three or five
years and then I think I don't know the
final has decided it and then right now
most of us are using the 3-year
follow-up who you are- your normal when
you have
of high-risk this you need a reflex back
to psychology and the cytology they will
take the thinkpad make the smear and
they read normal follow up just like the
HP b- follower and then if they have
even a skirts or higher so that abnormal
you go right to the biopsy and by us is
can be read by the psychologist they if
your result is 16 or 18 or 16 plus 18
you go right to biopsy this is the test
that's very specific and by doing that
they can go on to treatment remember
again HPV cervical cancer is a
preventable disease very in mind the
only way you can take advantage that is
to get tested and that is a very very
important to me message to everyone so
conclusion HPV code testing do they do
improve patient care for the past many
years and then because there's some come
from the result and then we are been
waiting for the next generation test so
he sets the futures here FDA finally
approved HPV testing as a primary screen
that means that so who you collect the
pap smear is going to go to the lab
first and we'll do the test who is
positive the 12 or pasta 1618 the vial
were automatic 42 cytology this was only
a month ago and indoors they also
approved the algorithm so primary HPV
screen using the HPV test for HPV 16 18
while reporting 12 are the high-risk
type we know people call this is oiling
one has all in one run from one sample
can be directly reflects to psychology
so and so so this is the end of the
story about the laboratory test the good
news now we have a solution and the
server other companies are working on
the same thing so now when the women
come
to the office and the clinician can have
good news to tell them they can detect
accurately and if you detect positive
they could go on treat treating and this
test is being recommended for women 25
years and older so the onus is on our
primary care ob-gyn and clinicians to
explain to the contender new patient
convince to them and I'm pretty sure
they're going to take many years for
women that being so used to comfortable
with the pet it would take time to
change but change is good changes work
better for all the people behind younger
generation so so just this like to
remind everyone there are two dressings
and then also 2009 disbursing and then
the best thing does 1618 cervix from a
bear Walken also FDA cleared this is the
only one is clear for male boys and the
girls and the hope other parents and see
this heard this presentation and then I
checked the data talked to the batter
make sure have their kids even their
kiss 20 they need to get it resonated
and boys and girls after all girls get
contracted HPV from such a contact on
boys so here is a look I really how you
can help protect both your son and
daughter with HPV vaccine and big smile
on both boys and girls and then I want
to thank everyone in my lap who support
a need for me to able to do this talk
and then I want also special acknowledge
dr. Janice Matthew Gray who supplied
with me several a really really
important slide and let's end up my talk
and thank you very very much for signed
off participate and this Web MA and then
I guess hopefully everyone
yeah we're going to start with Q&A by
everyone to submit a question by typing
in and then that's the end of my
presentation thank you very much so i'm
reading the Duke University naveen ganda
question how expenses how expensive is
each HPV pep screening test I know the
HPV test you know I'm a loud person HPV
test is around it costs about 20 little
bit over 20 then pap smear I'm not quite
sure probably comparable and that's as
fast no perhaps better check with your
clinician and it's affordable and also
most time insurance do cut insurance do
cover so I'm sorry I didn't click the
right thing how expenses are at each HPD
pep screening test remember the
screening test down the last of the HPV
right now at the Cleveland Clinic we use
HPV impact and that's I know HPV cost us
around you know most at $27 pap I don't
know maybe 20 40 because you're paying
someone to do that but it's affordable
and then in the Cleveland Clinic and
this is reimburse reimbursable from the
different insurance
questions any more questions you check
do you try it okay do you try to educate
scientists around the world with today's
new knowledge the question is do you try
to educate scientists around the world
with the today's newland knowledge I'm
not the expert but I try my best to get
the message out so the answer is yes all
of us all of us in the hospital or other
hospital in this health career britty
should do the homework and pass around
the world that's why you call educated
scientists and then I will hope to pass
my message to at least feel view the
answer is yes is very important is the
test usable for other types of sample so
the answer is yes the answer is yes we
did a study we actually did a study a
see answer did I clip right click tech
Q&A okay where the we actually did a
study and recently when we published the
next few months and we're using the fine
needle aspirate so the tumor cell from
head neck people with head neck cancer
and then we did about hundred sample and
then about 30 40
Santa tumor cell they were positive for
HPV and they were all HPV 16 and so we
were really alert however remember um
when a chair in the head neck cancer is
positive for HPV actually supposed to
have a much better prognostic result
because it's treatable in response to
radiation therapy so in a way for you
have a head neck cancer getting the HPV
test could be a good thing and then
actually help the doctor to manage the
patient the treat a patient let's see
any more question okay are there any
public here good question any point of
care HP passes available I understand um
in Europe there's one remember for
YouTube molecular test it is not
dipstick like the flu test or glucometer
in a glucose that other quick HPV HIV
serology tests so the answer is yes
there's several rapid HPV test but it
takes little less than an hour and they
can do it because so you need to have
the nuclear acid hybridized you're so so
the answer is a there are upon the care
that instead appointed care for HPV pet
they actually call a rapid HPV test so
the answer is yes that is this available
by understand are several and cup of
china couple europe let's see any more
question coming in
rosana Martin lolly thank you for
listening to my presentation I
appreciate your email and I thank you
all for signing for this webinar I'm
waiting to see up more questions ok I
think I think they're no more question
right thank you very much